ti quinze jours les dernières
statistiques sur l'enfance en danger les
cas de maltraitance sont stables voire
en légère baisse mais les signalements
sont en hausse
rappelons qu'un enfant est signalé comme
étant en danger lorsque les services
sociaux estime que ses parents ne
remplissent plus leur rôle
l'observatoire de l'action sociale qui
fait ce constat attire notamment
l'attention sur les risques liés à
internet
explication julia delage sylvain
gauthier bianca vient d'avoir 17 ans le
soir après les cours pas de télé ni de
téléphone avec ses copines elle préfère
le chat
comprenez les forums de discussion sur
internet elle s'y fait de nouveaux amis
mais parfois ses interlocuteurs ont des
propos pour le moins déplacés face à une
si jeune fille une fois je suis allé sur
le site de 15,18 enfin si les tranches
d'âge ont éclaté je suis tombé sur un
homme qui avait 25 ans et qui commençait
à me faire des avances sexuelles c'est à
dire est ce que tu as une webcam je
reviens de voir site est bonne c'est ce
que c'est qu'une fellation tu peux même
faire une pipe
enfin les genres grand chose et c'est
vrai que c'est un but ça arrive très
très vite en effet nous avons nous même
tenté l'expérience un pseudo une salle
réservée normalement aux 10 14 ans et en
quelques clics quelques secondes des
dialogues de plus en plus crus des
propositions sexuelles explicites
le phénomène est difficile à chiffrer
mais selon une étude européenne sur
internet
un enfant sur trois est approché
sexuellement alors pour prévenir et
sensibiliser parents des enfants
l'association innocence en danger lance
aujourd'hui une campagne d'information
est un logiciel de contrôle parental
il faut pas laisser seul son enfant il
faut regarder ce qu'il fait dans sa
propre pour sa propre sécurité pour la
sécurité de toute la famille donc cette
oui c'est un contrôle le mot paraît
négatif mais ce qu'il ya derrière le
rebond est derrière le projet est
positif les pouvoirs publics conscients
du danger ont déjà formé plusieurs
brigades pour traquer les maniaques de
la toile en bref